Speaker 1: After being arrested, the failed
former President Donald Trump drove right
to the airport and flew directly back to Florida.
There was an event promoted that was scheduled
for 8:15 p.m. Eastern last night where Donald
Trump was expected and believed to speak about
the arrest.
And potentially it would even be a press conference
where he would take questions.
He did not take any questions and Donald Trump's
brain seemed to disintegrate during the event.
Instead of talking about yesterday's arrest,
the charges against him and his defense.
He attacked both the judge and the prosecutor
and kind of ran through his generic list of
grievances seemingly focusing on other crimes
he may have committed.
Very, very strange event.
So let's start with the claim that Donald
Trump makes that because he was president,
any documents he takes from the White House
are by sort of like automatically declassified.
That's not how it works.
But again, Trump seems to be focusing on other
crimes he may be arrested for rather than
the crime for which he was arrested yesterday.
Speaker 3: To give up.
But isn't that real obstruction?
That's obstruction.
As president.
Speaker 1: Also, you'll notice Trump breathing
in a very strange way, just sniffing the entire
thing and everything every detail about this
speech was bizarre.
Speaker 3: The right to declassify documents
and the process is automatic.
If I take them with me, it's automatic declassified.
Biden was vice president.
He had absolutely no right to declassify as
vice president.
He doesn't come under the Noncriminal Presidential
Records Act.
He comes under the very criminal federal Records
Act, unfortunately for him.
But it's not going to matter because they
don't follow the law, which has very severe
penalties.
Speaker 1: So, first of all, it is not automatic
that if a president just stuffed some documents
into his pants and then leaves, that they
are declassified.
Secondly, this was not why Donald Trump was
arrested yesterday.
This is a completely different potential set
of charges.
Remember, we've got the Georgia Fulton County
investigation.
That's not what Trump is talking about.
You then have the investigation related to
the search warrant served on Mar a Lago.
That is what Trump is talking about.
But those are different possible crimes rather
than the ones for which Trump was actually
arrested yesterday.
Trump then attacking the judge, saying the
judge hates Trump and that the family hates
Trump, the judge, his wife and the judge,
his kids that every everybody just hates Trump
to have numbers.
Speaker 3: Not the same place that I know,
not the same place that you know.
And this is where we are right now.
I have a Trump hating judge with a Trump hating
wife and family whose daughter worked for
Kamala Harris and now receives money from
the Biden-Harris campaign.
And a lot of it.
Speaker 1: Trump knows exactly what he's doing
here.
Trump is signaling.
Trump is spotlighting.
Trump is putting a target on the judge and
the judge's family.
And it's not like we don't have evidence that
Trump supporters are willing to become violent.
We know that they are.
I mean, of course, there's January 6th.
You can also go back further.
And there was the guy with the think it was
pipe bombs who was arrested and what year
was it?
2017, 2018.
We know that there are people in Trump's cult
that will do violence.
And so when Trump starts targeting, I mean,
the the judge, his wife, why is the judge
his wife even in Trump's mouth?
Why why is why is the words the judge's daughter,
why is that coming out of Trump's mouth?
He knows what he's doing.
It's not only the judge that Trump attacked,
he also attract attacked the district attorney,
Alvin Bragg, saying actually they should arrest
and indict Bragg.
Speaker 3: The criminal is the district attorney
because he illegally leaked massive amounts
of grand jury information.
For which he should be prosecuted.
Yeah.
Or at a minimum, he should resign.
Speaker 1: There you go.
Of course, there is no evidence that Alvin
Bragg has committed any crimes whatsoever.
And as we've talked about before, it's law
and order.
Until law and order is no longer convenient.
And then it's just like indict my political
enemies.
No big deal.
Not a not a problem.
Trump then again, continuing to focus on his
other possible crimes.
Again, you know, his brain is mush.
Trump says that they are.
I, I actually struggle to understand this.
Trump seems to be suggesting that the search
warrant served at Mar a Lago was illegal and
also that they maybe want to put Trump to
death with the Espionage Act.
It's really hard to follow this.
Speaker 3: Reasonable search and seizure.
But they did it anyway because our justice
system.
Has become lawless.
They're using it now.
In addition to everything else to win elections.
Apparently they're not looking at me through
the view of the Noncriminal Presidential Records
Act.
They came up with a new one.
This is a new one.
And they're looking at me through the Espionage
Act.
Think of that.
How does that sound of 1917 where the penalty.
His death.
Hmm.
Even though that has absolutely nothing to
do with openly taking boxes of documents and
mostly clothing and other things to my home,
which President Obama has done.
The Bushes.
Speaker 1: It was mostly clothes, guys.
The fact that there were a couple hundred
classified documents, that doesn't matter.
It was mostly like shirts.
Speaker 3: And Jimmy Carter done.
Ronald Reagan is done.
Everybody's done tracked.
Hillary Clinton got rid of Clinton.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So anyway, I guess he's saying the search
warrant was illegal and that they are considering,
I guess, or want to give him the death penalty,
which is pretty wacky stuff.
Trump also claims that he doesn't need any
banks because he has a lot of cash, which
of course, raises the question of why Trump
is desperately asking for money.
If you have so much money, why are you asking
your followers You're a billionaire.
You're asking people who make $32,000 a year
to donate money to you.
Speaker 3: But they didn't lose a dollar with
this during this period of time.
In fact, the banks we're talking about made
almost $200 million off Donald Trump.
And they like me very much.
We never missed a payment.
Never got a default notice.
Had a great relationship with all of them.
Sure.
I don't eat banks.
We have a lot of cash.
Speaker 1: A lot of cash.
But he's desperately raising money anywhere
that he can.
CNN in a kind of funny moment, cut away from
the speech and was confused about why Trump
isn't talking about yesterday's arrest, which
is sort of the most newsworthy thing going
on.
Speaker 3: I know our currency is crashing
and we'll soon notice.
Speaker 2: The former president speaking tonight
at Mar a Lago back here in New York with the
panel.
Also, I mean, this is a reprise of we were
waiting for him to talk about what happened
today.
He finally talked about a little bit at the
end there and now we're cutting out of it.
I love I.
Speaker 1: Love Anderson Cooper's confusion
about what that.
Speaker 2: Was, but a reprise and pretty much
every grievance.
If you are a Republican who cares about the
Republican Party and the future of the Republican
Party and you are watching this tonight, realizing
this man now may be more powerful in the Republican
Party than he was yesterday, or at least a
little bit.
Speaker 1: More So anyway, CNN bravely cutting
away, but only about 90 seconds before the
speech ended.
And then lastly, here is Trump just abruptly
wrapping up the speech and walking off.
Speaker 2: Oh, no.
Speaker 1: Did we lose this clip?
Is this clip glitchy?
This clips glitch here than Trump's speech.
Hold on.
Here we go.
Speaker 3: With all of this being said and
with a very dark cloud over our beloved country,
Yeah, I have no doubt, nevertheless, that
we will make America great again.
Thank you very much.
God bless you and God bless America.
Thank you very much, everybody.
Speaker 1: Thank you.
Isn't that great?
He spends 30 minutes attacking everyone and
talking about how the country is just horrible.
And he wraps up by saying, despite all of
the horrible things I've spent the last 30
minutes talking about and all the possible
crimes I just admitted to, things are going
to be just great.
I'm running and vote for me and we're going
to make America great again.
So.
Trump's brain.
Mayonnaise.
Or maybe a béchamel.
I don't know what it is, but certainly something
is a little bit soft up there.
And it was just as crazy earlier in New York
City.
I want to talk about
that next.